first of all um
i have quite a history in las vegas you
know i used to do uh
afternoons at hot 97.5 out there um
so right on the street somebody heard
you once or twice i used to live off of
the 15 in craig
yeah i know that's that that's out uh
north yeah north side yes it's north
and uh yeah man i love vegas is uh
i kinda like my i love it out there man
that's like one of my second if i like
my second home low key you know what i
mean so
you know you're a vegas guy yeah i love
vegas man i'm saying it's definitely
yeah vegas my that's my home too for
sure yeah and they go yeah man it's my
spots how long um like
so were you originally from san diego or
vegas no i'm originally from detroit
okay originally from detroit how long
have you been in the west coast [ __ ] man
my mama moved me to the west coast so i
was probably like two one and a half two
so when i was in so being born in
detroit i never uh like i like i said i
can't tell you no streets are nothing
out there right of course because i
never lived out there but i moved to the
west coast and like i said man [ __ ] all
my people been taking me to daygo [ __ ]
so i was like 12 13. yeah i'm saying
start riding my homies and [ __ ] you know
i kind of got a lot of my season from
around there you know especially
bouncing back from both places you know
what i'm saying because vegas is fast
just within itself vegas is crazy i was
their main [ __ ] before some of the
casinos got torn down no they were in
the front wild yeah no for sure man it's
definitely uh it changes every day
the thing about vegas is like you said
like
you could go there
and not be there for like two months and
come back and be like the [ __ ] they put
how they build it so fast or they knock
this [ __ ] down or this [ __ ] got thrown
up it's crazy yeah let you know that
life moves without you whether you're
there or not a hundred percent man no
just the whole like uh vegas lifestyle
is one like once you leave vegas it's
very hard to shake that lifestyle like
it took me a while to like
get back into like normal like i've been
trying to leave night clubs holding
drinks and [ __ ]
yeah and all the [ __ ] closed down at two
o'clock a lot of other places hell the
whole city shuts down right you know
vegas 24 7. man you can get whatever
whenever however 24 hours a day seven
days a week the uh yeah and then
obviously just the hustle out there it's
crazy because vegas is like i feel like
it really helped me to live there
because it kind of put a permanent
battery in my back that never went away
yeah cause i feel like the city of vegas
you gotta be out there grinding it's
just it's a hospitality city like
everyone's on the on the grind like
whether you're parking cars whether
you're [ __ ]
you know i think that's probably why
um
no artists really blew up out of there
not saying there hasn't been people
that's came out of there because there
has been and they don't claim it they
won't say hey i'm from las vegas you
know they'll be the closest was probably
dizzy dizzy right
dizzy dizzy claims obviously baby keems
from vegas he's on tour with kendrick
yeah but there's was a lot of great
artists that just didn't get over the
top yeah you know i think i think it's
because and just just my outlook to it
like i think it's because there's really
no uh
not everybody see in vegas it vegas and
atlanta are different because atlanta
they really support their home artists
right they'll really like shut
everything down to go to you know say
somebody's concert and really go and
support as of in vegas like it's it's a
melting pot because everybody really
deep down inside everybody's from
somewhere somewhere else for the most
part you're right like a lot of people
from the bay a lot of people from l.a
you know what i'm saying like the the
the uh percentage of lost vegans are
slim you know what i'm saying they're
slim so you know people think that these
are a bunch of vegas people know these
are people from everywhere yeah shit's a
melt and pop people are here today going
tomorrow
for a job or they keep running or
whatever it is people are here today
gone tomorrow you know what i'm saying
so there's different type of [ __ ] and
different type of whether it's hustles
or people scamming whatever there's
there's new [ __ ] daily coming through
that city you know what i'm saying so i
think that's why it's always constantly
changing but even back to like just the
artists nobody's trying to help each
other because everybody's just trying to
help themselves yeah when i was there
like we had like a underground show on
sunday nights on the radio so we'd play
like [ __ ] interstate fats radio
ramone [ __ ] [ __ ] with interstate fats
i think uh yeah one of our old schools
in his video him in uh lausanne hmm fast
is great free fats man i've just texted
yeah that's my guy yeah he's a good guy
a beast yeah you'll be sweetie all your
beats with it for sure